hi it's balazar from the Green Bay
Packers and I'm playing start benching
hunt well I've never seen Rudy so I
might easily cut that one remember the
titans in the OG so I'm about to say
start from other times bench Friday
Night Lights sure moonwalk Carlton
dougie dougie is I think I'm going to
start that one start the dougie
moonwalks gonna get benched and cut the
Carlton will walk too smooth but only
one person's really like master dude I'm
around enough people that Doug you a lot
so and I was tough
I'm a big tiger fan Tigers gonna start
imma give imma give Brady the bench
I'm on the cuts arena I wish I'd gone
but I'm getting there so for sure
starting pizza especially with the
Italian sausage benching veteran wings
and then seven layer dip yeah that's go
public I go okay definitely Janet
Jackson starting that one queen bee
that's bench but then the app Katy Perry
even though I used to have a huge crush
on Katy Perry but sorry ok boys 2 men
starting for Shore and then I'm a bench
pts and cut it seek I got a kind of
thing this is al azhar from the Green
Bay Packers and I just played start
venting cut